So will you play my favorite game with me?
Yes. (chuckles)
We're playing "Behind the Scenes!"
Okay. (laughs)
(cheerful music)
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
(Judd laughs)
Okay. "40-Year-Old Virgin."
What's the inside thing?
Everyone would be riffing,
and Seth would be super hilarious,
and Romany Malco, and Paul Rudd, and Jane Lynch,
and everyone was like really funny.
And the crew looked at us like we were crazy.
(audience laughs)
They didn't get what the style was.
And so the set was really quiet.
It wasn't one of those sets
where the crew's like, you are nailing it.
I think it was like Clint Eastwood's crew,
and they were all used
to doing like one take.
(Drew and audience laughing)
Right?
So Clint does one take, he's like, "That's good enough."
And we would do like 20 takes and improvise for hours,
and it was all madness.
And they would just look at us like,
this is not how you do it.
All right.
(Judd chuckles)
I just watched it again for the, uh, 78th time,
"Knocked Up!"
Yes. (chuckles)
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Oh, it's the best movie ever.
(Judd chuckles)
Tell me something about it.
About "Knocked Up"?
Well, I mean, part of it was
when we were about to have a baby,
we were really looking for a doctor who would guarantee
that he would be there.
'Cause you know, sometimes the doctor's like,
"And if I'm busy, Chuck will show up."
You know?
(Drew laughs)
And we were like, "We don't want Chuck. We don't know Chuck.
We'd like to just have you do it,
so can you promise that you're in town this month or so,
and you'll show up?"
And the doctor's like, "Definitely.
I will definitely be there."
And then Leslie's water broke,
and we went to the doctor's office,
and the doctor said, "No, that's not your water breaking."
And then three hours later, she's in full labor.
And then we call the office and go, "Okay, it's time."
And they went, "Oh, the doctor just went
to San Francisco to go to a bar mitzvah."
(audience laughs)
So I think he lied and said her water didn't break,
and we didn't have another doctor.
So then we had to call a doctor that we didn't like
that we met to just pick a doctor,
and we called the one that we had rejected,
and he showed up like, oh, now you want me?
(Drew and audience laughing)
And that's who Dr. Ken Jeong was playing in the movie,
the angry doctor who showed up after being rejected.
And as it was happening, it was such a nightmare,
I just thought, one day, I just have to put this in a movie
'cause it's so terrible.
And then it all worked out.
I'm so glad you did.
Yeah.
I am so glad you did.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
Okay, talk to me about
sort of like Gen Z's "Sex and the City,"
the groundbreaking, "Girls."
The "Girls."
Well, I mean, the great thing about working on "Girls"
was Lena and just her writing.
I knew that she was doing things
that no one had ever done before.
And I don't think she gets enough credit
for really changing television.
Yes, I agree.
I mean, it was so honest and so frank,
and she went so deep.
And I think if you look at what TV was before and after it,
it had a dramatic effect
on what people thought that they could do on these shows.
And also, to have a woman as the writer, director,
showrunner, star, there hasn't been a lot of that.
There's been a lot more since,
and I feel like she opened that door
for people as well.
I totally agree.
(audience applauds)
Also, I'm so in love with Adam Driver.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's like the world's biggest movie star,
she discovered him.
"Trainwreck."
Yes, yes.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
"Trainwreck.
What about "Trainwreck"?
Well, I mean, "Trainwreck" was amazing
because I met Amy Schumer,
and then we had a few conversations about relationships.
And I would just say like,
"Well, what's going on with your relationships?
What's going wrong? Maybe you should write about that."
And then she sent me like 40 pages two weeks later,
and they were incredible.
And most people, you ask them a question like that
and say, "Write up some pages,"
and they just never talk to you ever again.
You just don't...
People don't deliver.
And she worked so hard and wrote such a great,
very honest movie.
And then we got LeBron James to do it,
which was this hilarious thing.
Huge.
Because I think she wrote his name
into the script almost as a joke.
And did you think
you would really get him?
Yeah.
Yeah, you don't like think he's gonna do it.
And then he just happened to be hysterical.
And he worked with Bill Hader on "Saturday Night Live."
And then he showed up and we shot all this stuff in a week.
And for that week, he just had to hang out
with us all day, every day.
Okay, "The King of Staten Island."
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
Is Pete Davidson as like adorable and crushworthy
as like all the women on the planet feel that he is?
(audience laughs)
Well,
suddenly-
I like funny men.
I'm getting the whole Tom Green thing right now.
I understand how it happens.
(audience laughs)
Right?
In that era, he was the Pete Davidson,
Adam Driver of the era.
He was a pioneer.
He did something before anybody else did.
He did almost everything before everybody else did.
I agree.
He even did the first
like internet talk show.
Since "Candid Camera," there was nothing like that.
Yeah.
But is Pete Davidson like,
is he just so delightful and wonderful?
And I feel like he's just got everyone on his side.
Well, he was really brave to sit down and write his story.
Yeah.
I mean, it's a fictional story,
but it's based on all the emotions he has about-
And the things
he went through.
About losing his father,
and grief,
and that's what I found most impressive about him.
'Cause there was never a moment where he said like,
let's not talk about that.
That goes too far. That's too personal.
He really wanted to share.
And by knowing Pete, I got to know all the firefighters
and the firefighters who worked with his father.
And that was really the best part of making the movie
was just to be in that community.
Judd, I just thank you so much
for everything that you put out
throughout the world.
Ah, thank you.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat pop music)